what we want to do is build this map of
the solar system so what does that mean
in a modern day and age well first off I
need to be in order to know where the
asteroids are now what I need to do is
it got built telescopes I need to
observe an asteroid and I need to watch
it move for some period of time so I can
figure out what its orbitals and then I
need to have math and I need to
understand orbital mechanics and I can
calculate the the trajectory of that one
particular asteroid and now I already
need to repeat by a million times
there's a million or so asteroids that
and I need to do that and I need to
update these things so the first thing
you need to building a really good map
at the solar system is telescopes
now this isn't that much different than
how we map the surface of the earth
you know we had spy satellites which
became commercial satellites looking
down at the earth and but the original
ones were built by governments and that
data was held secret and tightly held
eventually became open and eventually
became publicly available and a couple
of companies were able to take these
publicly available information and make
really good use of it different than the
way the CIA analyst and those types of
folks looked at things they built things
that were usable they built Google Earth
if you go masterbuilt MapQuest what we
want to do is follow that same tack we
want to take data from these telescopes
and these are some interesting
telescopes the one up there is one
called pan-starrs it's in Hawaii and
it's on the top of Maui and it is the
current most powerful telescope for
finding tracking asteroids on earth the
one in the middle is one called the
large synoptic survey telescope it is a
it is going to be the world's largest
survey telescope for finding asteroids
and looking into the formation and
evolution of the universe that was that
is being built currently in Chile by the
National Science Foundation for about
700 million dollars and it becomes
operational in
two and a half years and so that that
thing there is about 50 times more
powerful than this one and so what's
going to happen here is that the
publicly available datasets remember
this is paid for by the US government
it's going to explode
there's going to be an enormous number
of new discoveries now it's not going to
find all the asteroids we want to find
but it's going to do a heck of a lot
better than anything out there right now
so what it means we're gonna have a lot
of data what are we going to do with it
how are we preparing to deal with this
data how do we make that map out of this
data because really what this thing is
finding is not it's not producing a map
anymore than Google Maps is the same as
a bunch of photographs of the earth
taken by spy satellites somebody had to
build a system that allows you to
navigate around and allows you to do
things like turn-by-turn directions
you know place my store here that sort
of stuff all those things are what made
Google Maps useful that's not been done
for the solar system for navigating to
asteroids for calculating what if an
asteroid might hit the earth if for
laying resource claims for doing
deep-space navigation all those things
are going to be services built on a map
so maps are changing from
two-dimensional to four-dimensional and
they're changing from static objects to
services and and if you think about what
this map is going to be it's going to be
assert it's going to be is something
that exists in computers that people can
access and use and build off
[Music]